in the last video we covered the
essentials of dplyr and looked at some
basic built-in functions
in this video we're going to cover a few
additional packages you can load into
your art project to do even more data
wrangling we'll specifically look at
data cleaning
reshaping data and joining data sets
we'll be using the same data set as last
time the billboard hot 100 songs and
i'll leave a link to it in the
description
anyway let's get started so we're first
going to start by loading in our dplyr
and reader libraries and then loading in
our billboard 100 data set
we're also going to grab our code from
last time to select the date
up to the artist columns and then rename
the week's on board columns to week
popular
let's just go ahead and run that and see
what our output looks like we have our
date
our rank our song our artist and then
weeks popular
and this is all going to be in our music
df data frame
now looking at this data frame i do see
a couple of issues
right off the bat first of all if we
look at our date column we notice that
it's a character vector
so it's a little tough to do any kind of
time series analysis
ideally we want to convert it to a date
type another issue i notice is that this
artist column
doesn't only have one artist sometimes
it may have a featuring artist like
right here rihanna featuring drake
so we want to clean this up as well
we're going to go back to our code
we're going to create a new cell i'm
using command alt i to create a new cell
block
and then i'm going to load in the
lubridate package which helps us deal
with date and time values
and i'm also going to load in the string
r package which is really helpful for
string extraction and matching
and of course i'll put the links to
these cheat sheets for these packages
along with anything else i'll be using
down in the description so let's load in
these packages
now we'll start first by cleaning up the
date column like i mentioned it says
that it's a character vector so let's
convert it to an actual date
if we take a look at our looper date
cheat sheet we see that there are some
functions for parsing
date times it looks like we can use the
mdy function here to parse our date
column
so in our code i'll grab the music data
frame that we're working with
and i'm going to pipe that into our
mutate function which helps us add
columns
and our current column is called date so
we're going to replace it with a new
column called date
and we'll wrap date in that mdy function
so if we look at our date column now we
notice that the type is date and all of
the strings have been parsed
into actual date types so now we can use
all the other
date related functions from the lubridae
package such as floor date which takes
in a specific unit of time and it'll
round the date down to that unit
so if i grabbed all the distinct dates
in our data frame
we can see that there are a few in
january of 2011
some in february but if i wanted to
round down all of these data points to
be january 1st and all these to be
february 1st that way we could aggregate
our data based on month
it would actually be pretty simple i
could just pipe again create
a new column called month and then call
that floor date command from luberdate
we're going to pass in the date column
and then we can specify any unit of time
here but since we want to round down to
the month
we'll pass in month and now we can see
everything that happened in january has
been rounded down to january 1st
everything in february has been rounded
down to february and so on and so forth
we can also easily extract components of
the date like the month
the week the quarter etc and
additionally lubridate has functions for
dealing with date times so if you had
that data you could extract the hour the
minute the second
and so on now we also want to clean up
our artist column by splitting up
artists into two columns
we're going to have one column called
primary artist and another column called
featured artists
and we'll be using the strdetect and str
match functions that are built into the
string r package
str detect detects the presence of a
pattern of a string
so it takes in a string and then a
regular expression pattern
and then it returns true if that pattern
was found str match
allows you to extract the match groups
from a string so you can pass in a
string and a regular expression pattern
and it'll return a character vector with
all the matches and you can choose
which group you want to extract so if
that sounds a little confusing don't
worry let's just work through an example
so i'm going to delete upper code up
until this mutate command because we
want to keep that
new date column i'm going to make a new
column called primary artist
and this is where it gets a little
tricky so looking at our data frame for
primary artist
if the word featuring is in the cell we
want to grab everything before the word
featuring but if featuring isn't in the
cell
we just want to grab the actual value so
we're going to use the if else command
which takes in a condition
and then the value to return if the
condition is true and then the value to
return if the condition is false
so we'll start with if else and the
condition that we want to check first
is whether or not the artist column has
the word featuring so we'll use
fcr detect we'll pass in our artist
column and we just want to see if the
pattern
featuring is there now what value do we
want to return if featuring is in the
column we want to return everything
before the word featuring
so the next argument we'll pass in will
be strmatch
which helps us extract our matched
groups we'll pass in our artist column
and now we need to specify the regular
expression pattern to grab everything
before the word featuring
so we can use the dot to match any
character and then a star
to signify that it's going to be zero or
more characters and then we're going to
have a space
which will have to do a slash slash s
instead of just a slash s
because it's an escape character and
then the word featuring but str match
still doesn't know exactly what we want
to extract from here we want to extract
this part which is any character before
the space featuring so we're going to
put this in parentheses to signify that
we want to capture this group
and lastly if we were just to run this
on a cell it would return first
the full match which would be this whole
string so it would be
rihanna featuring and then the second
match which would be rihanna so we want
to grab the second group
so we're going to use the brackets and
grab the second value
now the last argument that we need to
pass in is what should we return if the
word featuring isn't there
and that's just the artist name so we'll
put an artist
so i'll close that off and we can run it
just to take a look
and let me actually just select artist
primary artist
just so we have him side by side and we
can see that when the artist does not
have a featuring
it just returns the artist name and when
it does have a featuring
it just returns what's before the word
featuring great and now we just want to
make one more column for
our featured artists so we'll delete
this code and
start writing our new featured artist
which is going to be similar to this
so we don't need to use an if else here
because if there's no match
it'll just return n a and that's totally
fine we can actually just use this str
match command so we'll actually copy
this
and now the only difference here is that
the artist that we're trying to grab
is going to come after the word
featuring so instead of dot star
space featuring it'll be featuring
space and then dot star in our capture
group
and again we need to pass in number two
here because if we did one
it would return the whole string since
the full match is always going to be the
first thing that's returned but by
passing in two we'll grab everything
that's in these parentheses
so i'll close off that so now i'll just
select our artist
our primary artist and our featured
artist and i'll zoom out a bit just so
we can see these
so anytime there's the word featuring we
see that we grabbed our primary artist
which is everything before the word
featuring
and then our featured artist which was
everything after the word featuring
and just from doing a quick spot check
this looks a lot better to me and i
think it'll be easier to do more
analysis on our data now
so i'm actually going to assign this
data frame now to be
music df dot cleaned and i can run this
whole cell
actually i'm also going to get rid of
that select so we have all of our data
and if i open this up we should have all
the columns we had before but also
our primary artist and featured artists
now so another common data scenario is
reshaping your data for instance if you
want to transpose your rows into columns
or vice versa
so we're going to load in the ti dr
package and i've already installed this
but it gives us some more functions for
organizing tabular data such as pivot
longer and pivot wider
so looking back at our data set right
now we have one column for primary
artist
and a whole separate column for featured
artists but if we wanted to reshape our
data so we just had
one column with all the artist's name
because right now they could show up in
either of these columns
and then another column specifying
whether or not
that artist for that row was a primary
artist or featured artist
we would have to reshape our data set so
let's try doing that with the pivot
longer function
pivot longer converts your specified
column names into one column
and it puts the respective values into a
new column so we'll grab our music df
data set
and let's just take a look at the
distinct song primary artist
and featured artist just so we don't
have a ton of duplicate rows
now like i mentioned we want to end up
with just song column
and artist column with all of the artist
names and then
another column let's say artist type
that tells us if they were a featured
artist
or a primary artist so we'll call pivot
longer
and we have to specify the columns that
we want to pivot on and we can do this
by indexing the column numbers so we're
going to do 2 to 3 which is the second
and third column we also have to pass in
a names2 parameter which is either going
to be primary artist or featured artist
so we'll call this artist type and we
also have to specify the column name
for the values so we'll just do artist
name
so if i go ahead and run this now we'll
have all of our artist names
contained in just one column and if
there is no featured artist it's going
to impute the n
a and if you're wondering why this might
be useful well let's filter for an
artist
and let's actually check out drake and
we can see that there's some songs where
he's a featured artist
and there's some songs where he's a
primary artist and theoretically going
back to our old data frame we could have
done a filter to check if
primary artist was drake or a featured
artist was drake
but having all of our artists in just
one column can be useful for other types
of analysis
for instance i can really easily figure
out how many times he was a featured
artist and how many times he was
primary artist just by counting on the
artist type
and we can see in all the distinct songs
he was a primary artist 135 times and
featured 48 times
but just a quick note if there's any
situation where there
are multiple featured artists and drake
is one of them then obviously this
filter condition won't match
so it would be excluding that data we're
not going to fix it now just because
this is a tutorial but that's just
something to keep in mind
so pivot wider essentially does the
opposite of pivot longer
it takes one column with a different set
of values and then makes those different
values into different columns
so for example let's just filter for the
songs that have ranked in the top three
spots
using that rank column that we have so
we'll filter where rank
is less than or equal to three and we'll
select
the date the rank and the song and just
take a look at that
so pivot wider as the name suggests can
make our data frame wider so right now
we have
rank contained in just one column but
what if i wanted to have
for each date a rank 1 a rank 2 and a
rank 3 column well that's when i'd use
pivot wider
so it's pretty simple to use we'll just
call pivot wider and now we have to pass
in
names from which is going to be the
column that we want to essentially make
wider
and that's going to be rank and then
we're going to pass in a values from
parameter
which is going to be the actual values
it'll impute into those columns
and that's going to be from our song so
if we run that now we have for each date
the rank 1 song in one column the rank 2
song
in another column and then the third
ranking song in the last column
now let's move on to merging some data
frames merging data frames is
definitely something you'll likely do in
r and it's really not too difficult with
dplyr so i found another data set online
of 10 000
mtv's top music artists and i'll put a
link in the description but let's check
out our data set
we've got the name of the artist some
social media links
and then the genre of the artist i don't
really care too much about the social
media links but i think it'd be useful
to connect
the artists in our billboard 100 data
frame with the artists in this data
frame
that way we can get the genre of the
music and maybe even see what the most
popular genres are
so before we start merging and joining
our data let's talk about the different
types of joins that there are
because it'll affect what your merge
data set looks like first is the inner
join
or just the join which will only keep
the rows of each table where there's a
match
so if there's a data point in the first
table that doesn't exist in the second
table
that row won't appear in our inner join
data set next is the left join or left
outer join which will keep all the rows
in the first table
but only the rows that match the
condition in the second table
so your merge data set will still have
all the rows of the first table
and then impute null values in the
columns of the second table if there's
no match
the right join or right outer join is
essentially the same thing as a left
join but it retains all the rows in the
second table and only keeps the rows in
the first table that match the condition
and then the full join or full outer
join retains all rows in both tables
i'm going to do an inner join here which
will drop all the rows in both the
billboard 100 and mtv data frames where
there's no match
so this means that any analysis we do
now will ignore potentially a lot of
data points and could give you
inaccurate results but we'll come back
to this in a second
so i've grabbed my music df clean data
set and i'll call that inner join
command
and we've already implicitly passed in
musicdf.cleaned as our first argument to
interjoin and we want to join it to the
mtv data
we also need to specify what column we
want to join on
so let's take a look at our column names
in musicdf.cleaned we want to join on
the primary artist
and on mtv data we want to join on the
name column
so we'll specify by which is going to be
how we're joining our data
and we're going to say primary artist
which is the column in the music the
updater frame
is going to be equal to the name which
is going to be the artist column in mtv
data
and just to see if our rejoin worked
we're going to select our song
our primary artist and the genre and now
the song which comes from our music df
data frame
has a genre attached to it which comes
from the mtv data frame
so if we want to quickly do some
analysis to see what genres are most
popular in the billboard hot 100
let's filter out all of the n a rows for
genre
and look at our distinct rows so if
there were multiple songs that were in
the billboard hot 100 now we're just
looking at
each individual one and now we want to
count on the genre name
so we can see that there are 49
different genres and then if we want to
grab the top 15
we can just call top end 15 and now just
getting this in descending order
we'll arrange it with descending by
n and now we can see in order the most
popular genre is by how many
songs they have of that genre i think
it'd be interesting to see if there's
any visible trend in popularity of these
genres
over the last decade we can actually
really easily pipe our data into the
graph functions with ggplot2 so let me
load in our ggplot2 library
and instead of seeing how all these
genres vary over time
i just want to look at the top 5. so we
can take the same query that we wrote
before
i'm going to change this to 5 and i just
want to get these genre names
into a vector so i don't really need
this line to arrange it
but i am going to call the pull command
on genre and this will just get me a
vector
with the top five genre names and we can
use this when making our graph
let me just save this as top five genres
and set it equal
and let's come down here to where we
want to make our graph and
i'll copy a bit of this code maybe up to
here
so this is just joining our two data
sets together and now let's select
our date our song in our genre we can
see what this looks like
and now we want to filter for the rows
where this genre is in
our top five genre so we'll call filter
where
genre is in top 5
genres and initially this has 35 000
rows
but if i run this we go down to 23 000
rows now i just want to see how many
songs of each genre are there for each
date
so i want to use that count function and
will group by the date
and the genre and now we can see on the
first week for billboard hot 100 of 2011
there were two contemporary country
songs 19 country
to hip hop and so on and so forth but i
do have a feeling that if we graph this
data it's going to be quite messy to
read
and we should probably aggregate this by
either month or year
first we'll take a look at what the data
looks like so we'll pipe this into
ggplot we're going to set our aesthetic
where the x-axis is going to be our date
the y-axis
is going to be the n value so the count
and then
we're going to pass in color just so we
can distinguish the different lines
and each line is going to be based on
their genre so we'll pass in genre
and then we just need to add the geom
line layer
and we can take a look let's zoom out a
bit
so this data looks pretty messy i think
it'd be better if we
aggregated the data by either month or
year so let's try doing that
we're just going to create a new column
called date that's going to overwrite
our previous state similar to what we
did before and we're going to call the
for date function
and let's pass in date which is the
column that we're going to floor by and
then the unit
which let's try a year and then we'll
pipe this into the rest of our data
so again this will take anything that
happened in let's say 2011
whether it's in january or february or
december
and it'll make it all january 1st of
2011
and then for 2012 it'll make everything
that happen in 2012
into january 1st of 2012 and this is
just so we can group our data by the
years
so if we run all of this now our data is
a bit smoother
and a little easier to interpret so just
based off this graph it looks like most
of these genres have decreased in
popularity over time
especially pop and country so it's
possible that some of the other genres
became more popular but what's also
possible
is that when we did an inner join with
our mtv dataset we might have
unintentionally dropped a lot of rows
for more recent years and this would
certainly be the case if the billboard
hot 100 artists
from the last few years weren't in the
mtv data set to begin with
so we'd need to further investigate if
other genres are becoming more popular
while the top five are becoming less
popular or if we just have a lack of
data these were some advanced deep
player concepts i felt were worth
covering
but if you do any kind of data wrangling
or data cleaning i'm sure you'll be
using at least one of these packages
thanks for watching and i'll catch you
in the next one